why would a male
choose to live with his parents for
longer versus a female who's like
bye-bye i'm leaving i'm going to college
i'm going to go you know at least i'm
going to follow the at least 500 miles
away from home rule
yeah i i think you see it in some of the
national stats right unemployment rates
for for males at the same educational
level females in some cases are are more
pressured or
for those without a college degree
males kind of screaming more negatively
than females so you know i think it's uh
you know our sex being a little bit
lazier and probably playing too many
video games to
um matriculate up but oh my gosh i'm
gonna have to save this for my teenagers
i'm gonna clip what you just said
anyways sorry sorry to interrupt going
um but something is is actually when we
when we dug into the factories or there
are different things people are
speculating on well is it just an
unemployment thing so if you can solve
the unemployment problem and you saw the
share at home but we actually separated
the cohorts between those that are
employed and those are not either
part-time or full-time
and you actually saw even among
full-time employed young adults the
share at home had gone up over the last
10 years so it's almost a willingness to
be at home
whether that's because you're trying to
save for something or you just prefer to
be at home the parents prefer to have
them at home there certainly seems to be
less stigma around living with your
parents at an older age than there used
to be
um one of my colleagues brought up uh
when we just read the reports it makes
me think about that that old show get a
life um with chris elliott and i haven't
heard that sometime but you know it used
to be you know literally get away get
out of the basement but now it's not as
much of a stigma
um so the one thing that we found if
they're going through all these
different factors that actually was very
telling was the decline in marriage
rates uh where as the younger
generations have either
or gone marriage altogether or decided
to get married later in life it's really
altered that trajectory to independence
and that's universal across the country
and that also wraps into less marriage
less lower fertility less likelihood of
having children so those two big
catalysts of marriage and children that
tend to
if you're not already on your own force
you on your own right those have been
under pressure so you can actually
explain some of this by pretty visible
factors so
less
less likelihood of getting married less
likely having kids in a higher
propensity of going to college
particularly among females
is sort of pushing out that formation
and and as you get deeper into the h
code or to get closer to 40 some of the
stuff balances itself out but it does
have a steeper trajectory to it
well plus if you're
even if you're putting off marriage as
opposed to never getting married the
longer you put off marriage the fewer
children you're going to have so it you
know you feed into
people not needing to move up as they
once did because maybe a different size
home is appropriate uh for their family
the flip side of that though is
if all these parents have all these
adult kids living at home with them
um they're not
moving down
they're not downsizing they can't
downsize if you get your kids if
your kids are living with you
right exactly and you look at the
different age cohorts there's obviously
a very big
difference between a 20 the 20 to 24
year old shared home versus the 35 to 39
share at home
um but all of those when you isolate
them individually all of those are up
first where it's been historically and
for the 30 year old cohort i want to say
it was probably running closer to 10 and
now it's closer to 12 or 13
so it might not sound like a lot to have
that 200 300 basis point increase but
it's just it's a net negative to
household formation and it's something
that
a lot of clients are focused on when
they're asking the question because i
think there's still this embedded
expectation that well that's just that's
crazy that's tailwind that's yet to come
they're eventually thinking about but
when you balance a lot of these things
some of them structural like around
marriage and college those types of
things with some of the other stats that
we've talked about which you look at
death rates for young adults and a lot
of people haven't paid attention to this
but over the last 20 years death rates
for 20 to 40 year olds are up massive
[Music]